the oscars were held last night it was
an event that passed almost an almost
entirely without notice if not for one
incident which we'll discuss in a moment
before we get there
it's worth reflecting on the fact that
award shows used to be ratings bonanzas
i mean there was a time in the not too
distant past when 40 million people 50
million people would sit around their
televisions on a sunday night and watch
a bunch of wealthy drug addicts give
themselves awards for five hours
those days are long gone
soon the era of televised award shows
will be officially over they'll no
longer exist at all
and our children will look at us with
bewilderment when we explain that once
upon a time we used to actually watch
celebrities give speeches about how
great celebrities are
they will certainly find that confusing
i have always found it confusing and i
lived through that era in history myself
the reasons for the disintegration of
the once popular award show genre are
many
one obvious factor is that the films
nominated and awarded are increasingly
obscure
last night apparently something called
coda won best picture nobody has seen
this movie nobody there there is a
debate raging right now about whether
the movie even technically exists nobody
knows if it does nobody knows where to
find it it seems that they just gave
best picture to um a movie that exists
only as a hypothetical like a theory
it's an abstract concept
and this is a reflection of the deeper
problem
hollywood infected with a terminal case
of wokeness
is more and more insular with each
passing day it's obsessed
with itself with its own moral
superiority
and that tremendous sense of
self-righteousness has caused it to
collapse in on itself
one of the consequences of wokeness is
that it obstructs a person's ability to
see beyond themselves
and this is true for anybody who
subscribes to this cult or is
indoctrinated by it but the effect is
amplified by a million
in hollywood because its denizens are
are already living lives of
incomprehensible privilege
these people are already artificial
basically self-obsessed over-indulged
coddled
you can see why they're all leftists
it is a worldview made for them and also
in large part made by them
they're not interested in even
pretending otherwise anymore now they
used to pretend they used to at least
pretend there's always been the
indoctrination the leftist
indoctrination from hollywood but it
used to be a lot more subtle they used
to pretend anyway to you know um to be
trying to appeal to a larger audience to
be able to relate to a larger audience
that is over now
last night judging by the clips that i
saw online anyway because of course i
didn't like everybody else i didn't
actually watch the show
they kicked things off by going
political right away wasting no time
just planting the flag right away this
is what it's about
and of course the first item on the woke
agenda was to virtue signal about the
fictional don't say gay bill that
leftists have invented watch
we're gonna have a great night uh
tonight and for you people in florida
we're gonna have a gay night
[Applause]
what courage what courage i mean it's
hard to fathom the bravery required to
stand on stage
in front of a room full of gay people
and say the word gay over and over again
this is this is what heroism is all
about and they kept playing the hits you
know later in the monog monologue they
threw in a bit about toxic masculinity
and also mitch mcconnell listen
you know this year we saw a frightening
display of how toxic masculinity turns
into cruelty towards women and children
damn that mitch mcconnell i know
yeah because
when you think of toxic masculinity the
first person that comes to mind is
mitch mcconnell
a little later in the night hispanic
actor uh john lugazano liguizamo took
the stage to applaud hollywood's
representation and all of the
beautiful
latinx faces listen
look at all these beautiful faces out
here
all these beautiful latinx faces we got
great representation here tonight people
oh sorry not not latinx latinx yeah
uh i always forget how to pronounce that
made up word i'm not exactly sure what a
what a latin x face looks like seeing as
how there's no such thing as a latinx
person
latinx at best sounds like the name of a
of a hispanic-only fan's site it's
certainly not the name for a group of
people especially because
if this sort of thing is important to
you
there are already numerous gender
neutral terms available to describe that
group terms like hispanic or even just
latin
but again wokeness is insular self
referential
it's gibberish to anyone who is not
already fully indoctrinated into it
that's why the left has to work so hard
and so desperately to indoctrinate
children into the cult because they know
that adults who grew up in saner times
are increasingly turned off by this sort
of thing
and are rapidly tuning it out in a
literal sense when it comes to the
oscars
that is people were tuned out
until the smack heard around the world
now you've no doubt already seen this
clip but let's all watch it again for
entertainment's sake if nothing else
watch
he is praying that will smith wins like
please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
it's javazone that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i jane jump keep my
wife's name out
now i'm going to okay
so i could oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay
truly the most atrocious thing will
smith has done since the aladdin remake
uh it's i mean this guy learned nothing
at all after spending all that time with
his auntie and uncle in bel air
on the positive side however
smith's physical assault of chris rock
completely overshadowed and drowned out
all of the virtue signaling that came
before it you know all the stuff lgbt
stuff they had all the ukraine stuff and
like all that's out the window
the celebrities in attendance wanted the
story to be about them heroically
chanting the word gay wearing blue
ribbons in support of ukraine
they didn't want this to be the story
that's also why you shouldn't buy into
any conspiracy theories that the
incident was staged okay it was not that
that's a more absurd
idea
than the incident itself was now maybe
the vma circa 1997 may have staged
something like this but not the woke
oscars of 2022
this is entirely real
and we should admit the most
entertaining thing that's happened at
any awards show in at least 25 years
personally i might actually start
watching these things if the whole show
was just a bunch of celebrities beating
the hell out of each other on stage like
a really well-dressed version of
celebrity death match
but as fun as it may be to watch
that was nonetheless a physical assault
which was committed on national
television in front of literally dozens
of viewers something tells me that if
you or i had walked onto stage during an
event of that kind
or any other kind and committed assault
against a presenter right in front of
everybody we'd be in handcuffs within 15
seconds instead will smith sat back down
enjoyed the rest of the show even won
best actor later in the evening
where he proceeded to cry and paint
himself as the victim of the physical
assault that he just committed listen
[Applause]
richard williams
um
was a fierce
defender of his family
i'm being called on
in my life
to love people
and to protect people
and to be a river to my people
i mean scientology really messes with
your brain uh just don't don't try it
kids even once
only in hollywood can a man assault
another man and then 20 minutes later
give a tearful speech about the power of
love
i'm a river to my people by smacking
chris rock
also keep something else in mind will
smith and this is the most important
thing about this incident to keep in
mind um he has bragged publicly on
multiple occasions about the fact that
his wife sleeps with other men
he has long been out of the cuckold
closet very open about the fact fact
that his wife enjoys jumping in bed with
strange men so any temptation you might
feel to take his side to argue that this
was a husband defending his wife's honor
as i've seen like a few people a few
conservatives even have said well this
is this is right this is traditional
values the traditional values he's in an
open he's a cuckold in an open marriage
with this woman he laughed at the joke
at first and then looked over at his
wife scowling and said oh
this was him
doing it primarily
as this was another act of of
emasculation by him
and any
temptation you have to defend him must
be mitigated by the fact that to will
smith defending his wife's honor does
not include preventing other men from
having sex with her
so you can
you
you dare not joke about his wife but you
can't have sex with her now that's a man
of principle
as a couple there's no honor left to
defend he doesn't have any neither does
she
how can he defend what doesn't exist
but then again they did award best
picture to a movie that doesn't exist so
who knows anymore
it's clear that the smack was not an
honorable man fiercely defending his
wife from an extremely mild joke about
her hair it was rather a privileged yet
broken and emasculated man lashing out
like a spoiled child and doing what no
normal person in this country would be
allowed to do and get away with it
he did what he did for his own sake
because he could
later that night he was filmed at an
after party dancing and singing
while a crowd cheered him on
you or i would be sitting in a jail cell
right now still
he was at an oscar's party prancing
around with his golden statue
apparently the trauma he suffered from
chris rock's joke was not enough to
prevent him from dancing you know a
golden statue can heal even the deepest
wounds i suppose
now given that this was black on black
violence and both men involved are
fairly liberal you may be wondering
whose side the woke crowd would take
because it's not maybe not not
immediately clear how this is all going
to shake out
but then when you think about it there's
no real mystery
one of the central tenets of leftism is
that words especially words in the form
of jokes are violence
i mean they hate stand-up comedians the
most and so of course assaulting a
standard comedian they love that
the emerging consensus on the left uh
therefore is that will smith was
justified because chris rock's joke was
a form of violence this was self-defense
against a violent attack by a comedian
that's the justification anyway as
offered even by prominent politicians
like ayanna presley and jamal bowman
but the real justification is that will
smith is a non-white left-wing hollywood
celebrity and so he's allowed to do
things that the rest of us peons cannot
do
that is the privilege of leftism
an ideology that in so many ways exists
in its own universe
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated